[Music]  hi I'm good how are you good good to see  you look great oh those eyes they are  sexy still got it  what's been going on been busy mr. voice  I haven't really heard much from ya just  busy yeah right we'll meet you I'm busy  doesn't fit somehow for you I don't know  maybe I'm from a different mindset like  if you love somebody you'll do whatever  it takes to be with that person I mean I  would like just to have more time with  you more communication but I feel like  you don't I think that communication is  key and I respect you I feel when I say  to you I'm in a business meeting I'll  call you later and I get 1500 text  messages that's not you respecting me  I've tried  don't ring people at 5:00 a.m. it's long  distance there's so much going off in  terms of work I feel like I can't give  this love and time do you want  [Music]